hello and welcome to the
third php tutorial in this tutorial
we're going to be discussing
uh putting html within php
and then putting php within html
so you've already seen us put html
initially at least into php in the
previous tutorial where we put the
strong tags
so first let me just show you throwing
in a quick php script
within an html script
so what we're going to go ahead and do
is make a quick
just html input text box
so and again if you're not too familiar
with html just follow along
um html is really really basic uh
and there's plenty of tutorials i might
have tutorials on html at some point if
i do i'll just edit this and append
or put up one of those little
annotations or something but
anyway we're going to put an input type
equals
text oops text and we'll say
value equals and what value is is like
what's going to be
in that that text box
initially like before someone actually
types so
that value what if we made that value be
some sort of php
script that derives the value so let's
add
php tags and let's make the script so
there's our tags
question mark php and then ends with a
question mark
closing tag and within those php tags
let's say we want to echo
the language so we'll just echo
dollar sign lang for the
for our variable that's defined up here
as always with php
end with the semicolon even though this
is really one line so i guess you
wouldn't have to end with that semicolon
but
you might as well get used to putting
that semicolon so
and at least i might as well get used to
it so i'm going to keep doing it
so anyway this is really html and then
we've got a short
but it is a php script within the html
so with that let's save it and let me
put this up on the server hopefully i
didn't typo anything i like to typo
and we'll run it and it says welcome to
php oh we didn't remove that but that's
okay
but as you can see we've got this text
box and the default value in this text
box
is indeed php but of course we can
delete that and type whatever we want
so let's pop back over here and let's
get rid of this html or actually
let's just change up the html a little
bit and let's just say
the value here is just html
example and let me get rid of this echo
and real quick let me pop this back onto
the server
so you can see what we're dealing with
see this is html outside
of the php now and there's no php within
the html
so this is just html but what we can do
is we can throw this html within
our php and that is going to be just
echo and then you echo a string and what
we're going to do is literally just copy
and paste or actually cut and paste
that to the echo now if you'll notice
within this echo we've got um the text
is kind of finicky here we've got
this literally going black on us and
that's because
we encased everything in a quote so it
gets
this single quote and it thinks this is
the end of the string and then at this
point it's like what
and then it's like okay we opened up at
a quote again and then we've got double
quotes and then
things got really messy and so in fact
what we can do is we can replace these
double quotes with single quotes first
off
and then what you do is use the
backslash it's above your enter or
return key
and you do that and it's called the
escape character and you just escape
all of these quotes that you don't want
to
actually hold you know a value of a
quote
so anyway after we've escaped all of
those
the other thing you can do instead of
escaping all of these is just in case
the entire echo statement
in double quotes
but for the most part i pretty much
program everything in single quotes
but anyway yeah the options are there
for pretty much whatever you want to do
um i'm pretty sure the standard usually
is actually to code
everything in single quotes and escape
the inside quotes
but i have seen people that will say you
know hey you should really encase
everything in double quotes but
whatever anyway save that upload it back
to the server
and now as you can see we've got php
script here
and within it we're just echoing some
html which will be read by the server
and inputted most likely
and we save it we see html example but
let me just switch this up a little bit
and say or html and php
just so you know like it really did just
get uploaded to the server and
changed and we'll pop back over here
save it or refresh
and yeah so now you've got html within
php
so those are the basics of php within
html and html within php you might
decide to do it whatever way
for a whole variety of reasons so
um anyway hopefully you all enjoyed as
always thanks for watching and until
next time